bonjour alain pantel merci de répondre
aux questions sur arte france
l'armée a renversé l'ex chef du
gouvernement ou de son soutien au 1er
février trois mois et un jour après les
manifestations perdure jusqu'à quand
quelle issue possible quel scénario est
ce que vous envisagez pour ces
prochaines semaines
vous savez ce qui est formidable c'est
de voir que c'est la population entière
toutes les villes tous les villages qui
s'y révolter contre le pouvoir militaire
vous avez très bien expliquer les
manifestations
ce qui est dramatique c'est que le les
manifestations au début ont été
contrôlés en vain ils ont tenté de
contrôler par la police et par leur
unité spéciale et très vite ils ont été
débordés ils ont fait appel à l'armée
mais quelle armée ils ont fait arriver
les divisions qui d'habitude se battent
dans la jungle contre les armées de
détenus c'est à dire c'est des
militaires qui sont habitués à tuer
piller violer détruire les villages
décimé les populations et même
maintenant on voit dans les ethnies
l'armée ne recule pas à employer les
jets pour bombarder les zones rebelles
et tirent au mortier sur les
rassemblements de foules c'est des
barbares cd épouvantable et j'admire la
population qui a man u avec des frondes
avec des lance pierres se bat contre
cette armée
vous avez dit la population toute
entière
le pays on sait est traversé par de
nombreuses fractures ethniques un dîner
pas de parler des pique niques justement
avec ce mouvement de contestation est ce
qu'on peut voir émerger une unité inter
communautaires exactement et le
gouvernement provisoire qui s'est mis en
place à fait la place importante a fait
place importante aux à des ministres
venant des ethnies la population il ya
30 % de la population birmane qui
appartient aux différentes ethnies et
ses ennemis étaient déjà pour la plupart
en guerre depuis des décennies contre le
pouvoir central est maintenant toutes
les ethnies avec leurs petites armées
relativement bien équipé se sont ralliés
aux protestataires
donc c'est vraiment tout le pays y
compris les ethnies qu'il se bat contre
le pouvoir militaire
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui va se
passer ces prochaines semaines selon
vous parce que celle là ça fait quand
même trois mois et auxonne sushi qui
entame son quatrième mois de détention
en résidence en d'ailleurs quel avenir
pour elle ça je ne je ne connais pas
l'avenir de madame angot sociaux qui
elle est en résidence un épi dont elle
est protégée elle n'est pas dans la rue
comme le pays en entier et c'est la
population c'est les jeunes g j'admire
ils ont pas en disant qu'au nul internet
les téléphones mobiles la liberté ils ne
veulent plus jamais connaître le pouvoir
militaire
donc c'est vraiment tout le pays avec
une force formidable à vous pas vous
parliez des des morts oui et beaucoup de
morts et les morts par balles elle et
soldats tirent dans les têtes ou dans
les thorax avec des fusils à lunette
sûrement il tire jamais dans les jambes
comme le font certains plis et en plus
des morts je suis sûr que tous les
blessés
enfin beaucoup de blessés qui ont pas
été emmenés par l'armée dans les
hôpitaux mais ont été emmenés dans les
postes de police ou dans les prisons
tous ces blessés sont morts car on sait
que souvent les familles sont appelé le
lendemain pour aller chercher les corps
contre 100 dollars il faut qu'il paye
100 dollars pour pouvoir récupérer les
corps de leurs
de leur père de leur frère de leurs
épouvantables et les blessés certains
d'entre eux qui étaient recherchés ont
été extraits des hôpitaux privés ou des
hôpitaux de campagne qui avait été mis
en place et ils ont été retirés par les
militaires et emmené on ne sait pas où
donc le nombre de morts est sûrement
très supérieur ce qui est épouvantable
aussi contre ce régime militaire c'est
qu'ils ont arrêté les médecins ils ont
été les chercher dans leurs services
alors qu'il soignait des malades et des
blessés
ils les ont mis en prison moi j'ai des
collègues orthopédiste 1 je suis au top
et disent je vais depuis 40 ans dans ce
pays
j'ai plusieurs collègues qui sont
incarcérés maintenant dans la fameuse
prison de insein de rangoun et on est
absolument sans nouvelles d'eux aucun
pays au monde ne prêtent ainsi les
médecins
contrairement à toutes les conventions
internationales
je ne sais pas ce que fait la croix
rouge internationale juste devant la
communauté internationale on s'est
classé années l'onu ont appelé à un
apaisement ce week end
comment peuvent réagir les généraux
vis-à-vis de ça bah vous savez les
généraux ça fait 90 jours que il ya des
appels de tous les états de toutes les
organisations pour leur dire cesser le
général en chef là qui est allé l'autre
jour à jakarta à dire bah oui on
tergiversera quand le calme sera revenu
mais le calme
il ne peut pas venir tant que les
généraux ne seront pas
à même de rétablir de dire voilà on sait
ce toute action ce qu'il faut c'est les
étrangler financièrement car les
généraux à des grand problème c'est
qu'ils sont multimillionnaires les en
dessous aussi les colonels touche de
l'argent
l'armée possède un tas de conglomérats
et contrôler les l'épée est précieuse le
jade le pétrole le la drogue les tous
les métaux précieux
il faut absolument qu'on arrive à ce que
les grands groupes pétroliers arrête de
d'alimenter en finance la junte
militaire
ils ont qu'à mettre ça sur un compte
bloqué et que l'argent ne viennent plus
pour pouvoir payer les salaires des
troupes les salaires des policiers
il faut absolument que très rapidement
les militaires soient étrangler
financièrement et que enfin vous savez
hier le conseil de sécurité a renouvelé
sa confiance dans les termes des
décisions de l'asian de dimanche dernier
mais c'est des mots les généraux ils
sont bien tranquilles et le fait
cinquante ans que il n'écoute que d'une
oreille très discrète les
recommandations internationales
il faut maintenant frappé beaucoup plus
fort on va vers une guerre civile
invraisemblablement s'il n'ya pas
d'apaisement
du côté des militaires parce que les
ethnies sont sûrement de plus en plus
armés et ça va être un bain de sang
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
alain patin je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'association médicaux
médical franco asiatique